Today we are going to fight, we're gonna stand
strong for what we believe in: each other.
Last month the corridors of power in Washington
opened up to the world's oldest profession.
40 sex workers met with 30 members of Congress
to push back
against the Fight Online Sex Trafficking Act.
Why would professional lawmakers meet with
professional law breakers?
Reason tagged along to find out why.
So what we're doing right now is super exciting
because, as far as we know,
there has never been a sex worker lobby day
on the hill, but there is today.
We're going to be going to our representatives,
talking with them.
A lot of them aren't super familiar with sex
worker rights.
Particularly in the wake of SESTA and how
SESTA has impacted us.
SESTA is a bill that passed recently
that heavily restricts and criminalizes advertising
for sex work on the internet.
The Stop Enabling Sex Traffickers Act or SESTA
would allow sex trafficking victims to have
their day in court
by eliminating federal liability protections
for technology providers that knowingly, knowingly
facilitate online sex trafficking.
Today when the house votes on FOSTA, we will
be sending a clear message
businesses that sell human beings online can
no longer do so with impunity.
FOSTA stands for Fighting Online Sex Trafficking
Act.
It is a law that purports to fight minors
being forced into sex work
and it purports to do it by increasing liability
for online intermediaries.
The bill also provides increased criminal
liability and thus deters websites and individuals
from selling human beings online.
Websites will no longer be able to turn a
blind eye
or actively conceal this horrific practice
without facing very real consequences.
The federal government says if you're an online
platform,
you generally are not liable for what goes
on, by users, on your site.
FOSTA and SESTA before that are the first
steps towards enforcing more liability
allegedly to go after sex traffickers.
We're really fooling around in an odd way that you
don't expect.
We're fooling around with one of the legal
foundations of the internet
that's been really so successful particularly
with social media.
Cragislist and Reddit have already shuttered
sections of their website
citing FOSTA liability concerns.
Facebook, and other large technology companies
have backed the legislation
while a trade group representing startups
has opposed it.
Thank you very much for being with us today
as we sign this crucial legislation
to combat online sex trafficking and bring
criminals to justice.
Signing the bill was very much in character
for President Trump.
It's a bill in which it appeals to people's
gut instincts about things.
It doesn't ask questions about are we going
about this in the right way,
what are the costs, you know all of those
issues, populists don't ask those questions.
Thank you mister President.
The only surprising thing is he didn't support
it more strongly
and I think that's probably because he himself
has legal and indeed political issues
connected to various kinds of sexual issues
let's say.
Today Carl Ferrer, the CEO of Backpage.com
the man behind what authorities are calling
one of the world's top online brothels
facing criminal charges for the very first
time.
The purpose of government is not to make people
into better people morally.
If government's role is to enforce a majority
or a minority's view
you're going to be coercing people who are
pursuing their idea of what the good life is.
To even discuss sex work is something that
we weren't sure what the response would be for that.
And that is the problem that we're trying
to overcome here right now
is the lack of communication because we've
found that most people
don't even know what FOSTA and SESTA are slash
were.
And that they were very effectively manipulated
essentially
into believing that it was truly an anti-trafficking
law
when in reality it is hurting survivors of
trafficking and itr's really hurting sex workers.
Sex workers often advertise on the internet
as a way to screen clients.
And this is a huge help in keeping people
safe.
If you don't have the ability
to check on someone's criminal record for
example before meeting up with them
you don't know if they could be violent or
not.
And because FOSTA limits in a lot of ways
the ways I am able to advertise and run my business
it makes it more dangerous for me.
The Department of Justice had sent over a
letter, very last minute
kind of sticking to the, I don't know if I'd
call it ad hoc,
but the fast moving nature of the bill
that they obviously weren't even consulted
before it was brought to the floor.
And even DOJ was saying that they question
highly the constitutionality.
We live in a system where the process is supposed
to be deliberative, it's supposed to be fairly slow,
you're supposed to have committee work, it's
supposed to be informed and detailed
the original law had many problems and there
was a lot of informed criticism of it
and Congress on the house side was responding
but then suddenly it was pulled out of committee
on the house side
brought to the floor for a vote and passed
and then signed by President Trump.
Once it got out of that and got defines as
'are you for or against
coercively forcing children to engage in sex.'
You know, that was the definition and no one
was gonna vote for that.
These are tough bills because you, the titles
of them and what people say that they do-
it's a set up, because then it's going to
be an election year
and it's like 'well this person voted for
child slavery.'
He was great!
-find a meeting that goes better than that
one!
I mean he talked to us for an hour-
I don't often leave a building feeling hopeful
for my government.
Exactly, yeah feeling like 'wow I feel like
I'm being represented by my elected officials.'
Over 30 more congressional representatives
would open their doors to Jinx
and other sex worker activists that day.
And by the end of the month, the Electronic
Frontier Foundation
joined Human Rights Watch and the Woodhull
Freedom Foundation
in a lawsuit challenging FOSTA in federal
court.
What do we do?
Stand up, fight back!
I'm not saying I'm happy with Washington D.C.
I''m not saying I'm happy with the politicians.
I'm glad they did the thing that they are
supposed to do, which is represent us.
So you can't bring down the whole system overnight.
We can't decriminalize sex work overnight
either.
But as we continue to have dialogue with our
representatives.
Perhaps we can shift it a little bit closer
to the kind of government that we say we have.